[Musique]
dernière ligne droite pour les athlètes
réunionnais sélectionné pour les 10e
jeux des îles de l'océan indien à l'île
maurice ce samedi 6 juillet c'est
l'élite des sportifs réunionnais qui
s'étaient réunis à la villa du
département à l'occasion d'une cérémonie
hautement symbolique organisé par la
collectivité départementale a le sport
sur les départements ont fait mais
beaucoup ont été les ligues les comités
et entre deux projets baugé jeux des
îles on a fait un budget de 300 mille
euros donc moi je pense que dépenser
beaucoup pour le sport ici
pas seulement en général pas des grandes
équipes est aussi pas mal d'associations
que le département aide et annuellement
à cette occasion des cadeaux ont été
offerts aux vins jeunes du collège
marcel goulette vainqueur du challenge
sportif des collèges est le porte
drapeau de la sélection de la réunion a
été officiellement désigné les sept
candidats en lice c'est sébastien
maillot qui a été choisie à bien elle ça
me fait chaud au coeur je m'attendais
pas du tout à ça en vaut mieux être
sincère c'est vrai que je suis là je
suis présent depuis 98 sur les jeux des
îles c'est ma sixième participation
aujourd'hui du mois le 17 qu'on prendra
l'avion mais voilà j'ai toujours été un
sportif rayonner j'ai toujours été là
j'ai toujours apporté ce que j'ai su
faire aider les clubs voilà pour mouvoir
ma discipline au sein de la réunion en
attendant le grand départ pour l'île
maurice où se dérouleront les 10e jeux
des îles de l'océan indien
du 19 au 28 juillet prochain ses 275
athlètes représenteront la réunion dans
pas moins de quatorze disciplines
[Musique]